.
- Une toute petite planche
de bois. C'est le chemin que
10 0ererersonnes empruntent
depuis 5 jours pour quitter
Irpin, leur ville bombardée.
Le pont de béton a été détruit
délibérément par les forces
ukrainiennes pour ralentir
l'arrivée des Russes.
leleleles moyens sont bons
pour fuir. Les blessées font
aussi la route malgré le manque
de transport adapté.
Et tous ceux qui entament
la marche le font au péril
de leur vie, alors que les
bombardements se poursuivent.
Les négociations pour arriver
à établir des corridors
humanitaires qui permettrent
de sortir les civils des zones
de combats et de faire
entrer l'aide humanitaire,
sont complexes.
Me SOPHIE RONDEAU, cons. jurid.
droit intern., Croix-Rouge can.
- Il y a aussi beaucoup
de détails et de paramètres
qui doivent être mis en place :
les heures, les lieux,
les itinéraires d'évacuation,
l'ordre des personnes.
Et amemememement l'aide
peut être acheminée.
Donc, les détails logistiques
sont essentiels.
- Et surtout, les deux parties
opposées doivent s'entendre
sur les conditions pour établir
les corridors. Ce qui est loin
d'être le cas. Un cessez-le-feue
pour commencer l'évacuation
n'a pas été respecté
la semaine dernière à Marioupol.
Et l'Ukraine refus
les corridors proposés
par la Russie, qui amèneraient
les civils vers leur territoire
ou celui du Bélarus.
FRANÇOIS AUDET, Observ. canadien
sur crises et action human.
- La Russie dicte les corridors
humanitaires, invite
la populininininininienne
à venir sur son territoire.
On peut imaginer à quel point
ça peut servir la propagande
du président Poutine de
démontrer à la population russe
que les Urkrainiens veulent
venir en Russie, ce qui est
évidemment absolument pasasasas.
- Dans l'est du pays,
les combats se poursuivent
et n'épargnent pas les quartiers
résidentiels, comme ici,
à Kharkiv, où les résidents
se sont réveillés lundi matin
devant une scène de désolation :
des maisons et des immeubles
résidentiels réduits
à des décombres.
- Des civils victimes de la
guerre se présentent à l'hôpital
pour soigner leurs blessures
et pour partager leur expériencs
la deuxième plus grande
ville d'Ukraine.
- Pendant que ça se négocie,
malheureusement, les
bombardements continuent.
On est face à un massacre
historique,  c'est d'une très
grande i i i i i i i il faut
évidemment espérer qu'une
désescalade survienne
le plus rapidement possible.
- Petite lueur d'espoir
peut-être, Kiev estime que le
troisième cycle de négociations
russo-ukrainiennes, qui s'est
conclu en fin de journée,
donner des résultats
pour l'établissement
d'un corridor humanitaire.
Du côté russe, on estime
que des corridors pourraient
voir le jour dès demain.
Reste à voir si le devoir
humanitaire de protéger
les civils prendra le dessussus.
Ici Pasquale Harrison-Julien,
Radio-Canada, Montréa